where were you four years ago on the
night of January seventh honestly mr.
Allen I have no idea how far back does
this investigation of yours go I'm not
at liberty to discuss that with you
also um do you ever use public transit
with like the subway
I mean imagine me in a wheelchair more
like a bus is this really necessary
I'm just being thorough fine
I prefer lifts their wheelchair friendly
monster mr. Allen how our vehicle option
is important what a date I can hardly
remember I'm just trying to establish a
timeline solve a mystery mysteries are
for novelists and archeologists you were
supposed to be ruling me out as a
suspect
instead it seems like you've got your
guy oh no this is just procedure
feels like persecution no can I get back
to you or do I need to accompany you
downtown no of course not
just email me sorry to bother you
[Music]
hey what's going on I think we know who
he is the name we're looking for his
Clifford Clifford DeVoe for once we
actually have a chance here to get ahead
of our enemy she sees that it's
interfering with his work you're not
acting the way that you normally do
sabotage and Cadabra warned us about
someone named devour this de veau guy
could be behind everything Barry is
there a possibility that you were so
determined to find the bad guy and get
ahead of everything that you're seeing
things exactly the way you want to see
them no it seems like he's getting a
little crazed about this guy so I think
more than anything
iris is just concerned he's taking it
too far oh my god I don't understand why
you don't see what's going on he
probably has cameras everywhere at the
lab at CCPD I mean he's always watching
us when I left Earth I went through some
kind of wormhole quarrel calls that a
disruption and it took me to the future
and I've been living on earth in the
31st century for the past seven years
explains why is not allergic to let
anymore how Corp develops a cure about
four hundred years from now everybody we
got new flash let's break it down and
there is a new round of the blast ring
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber leave a comment on the
video uh that's a new winner at the end
of this it yes we finally have Legion of
super-heroes
on the DC TV show so I'll also explain
how that's going to work because they
are bringing Brainiac 5 on to the shows
so we'll finally have a legit version of
Brainiac but we finally have flash
versus the thinker but the thing is is
that he doesn't know anything about
Mobius chair thinker he only knows about
this devote person that he came to at
his house so he's a college professor he
just like slowly trying to piece a
timeline together of where he was when
the particle accelerator went off and
then separately when the bus incident
happened like he's trying to ascertain
when he may have gotten powers like
that's how he thinks this is happening
so he's not completely wrong and we saw
that other trailer where he's you know
in the foreground with all these
protesters in the background and you see
that flash effect where the Speed Force
is nearby and all the liquids start to
raise up so I've said it before but I
think the idea is is that he was
actually at STAR Labs when the original
particle accelerator explosion went off
and that's how he got hit with the Dark
Matter wave but he was not in the
wheelchair at the time so obviously the
thinker is lying through his teeth to
bury like oh you know I can't take
public transit I can only take the lift
because of my wheelchair so in the way
that they're doing a lot of callbacks to
season 1 this season they're also
calling back to Harrison wells being the
fake crippled riding around in the
wheelchair just because he was using it
to try and absorb more Speed Force so in
those other scenes in the last trailer
we saw the thinking cap lying on the
pavement and he slowly puts it on but
that's the last we see of it so there's
just like a slow evolution of the
thinker in flashbacks that we'll
probably get maybe through his
perspective because I think we're past
the point where Barry would just
willingly travel back into the past and
worry about messing with things again
flashpoint style because that would
really be the best way to search the
crime scene like you go back into the
past four years and run around while the
blast is
going off and just see if he's in the
crowd somewhere you can already imagine
the look on Jay Garrick's face if he
were to do something like that
so that's why they're giving him a
villain that's more of a Sherlock Holmes
situation like he actually has to use
his ability as a CSI and you've seen
that in the first couple of episodes to
where he starts rattling off a lot of
text speak but the really cool thing
about this week's episode and then
obviously the crossover is next week but
the stuff that's happening after the
crossover is that we're finally into the
thinker storyline we've got like a
little bit of him in each episode but
this is where they really start going at
each other and you can see it's slowly
driving very crazy because nobody else
believes him the actor that plays Jesse
Martin though also talked about Joe
trying to get one step ahead of the
thinker and they've only shot up to like
episode 12 I think I don't think they're
past Episode twelve at this point so the
good news is that sometime in the next
couple of episodes the rest of the team
will believe Barry something will happen
so they're not gonna push this too hard
this situation where nobody believes
Barry and he has no way to prove it that
can wind up being really frustrating for
audiences like when one character has
all the information and the rest of his
friends don't believe him they've done
that in previous seasons like when
everybody's lying to each other that's
why they sort of blew past that with the
killer frost storyline this season where
she just like comes clean to them right
away so like you can be on the team she
could do the killer frost stuff so the
same thing is gonna happen with the
thinker storyline in the thing that
people may have forgotten is that Barry
still has all those symbols that he
wrote when he came out of the Speed
Force it's basically a timeline of
everything that's happened or is going
to happen
they just haven't mentioned it in the
last couple of episodes so the evidence
to take down the thinker in out him and
solve you know whatever big problem that
the thinker is trying to use the flash
for is in those symbols but in order for
them to figure that out they have to
decode more of the symbols and then
actually like have a couple of them here
one of the things come to pass like when
he says this house is bitching like they
actually have to hear somebody say that
hey wait a minute that was Barry's
symbols maybe we should see if there's
something else in those so we'll start
decoding them more so if you think it's
funny that they haven't referred to
those symbols in a while they probably
going to bring those back relatively
soon and we haven't seen them decode any
of those symbols within eyeshot
of the samurai head so it seems like the
thinker does not know about all of these
symbols that Barry wrote down yet but
I'm sure that eventually all that
information will get out by the back
half of the season but they're just so
so many questions when it comes to
Mobius chair thinker and wheel chair
thinker because he doesn't have any of
the symbols carved into his forehead
he's not wearing any tech gear and his
actual house looks like a normal house
so I'm wondering what the thinking cap
has to do with this but in the comics
the thinking cap is this really classic
old thing that just enables him to
control other technologies so we'll see
what the thinking cap of the TV show
does but because we're getting ready for
the big four night crossover there might
be some more footage for that tonight so
if we get some new stuff then I'll try
to work that into the videos we've
gotten one new look at the reverse-flash
of the crossover the Blitz and flash but
it's been really blurry so I'm expecting
the next couple of trailers that we get
to actually show him a little bit more
but usually what happens with TV is that
they take up to like the last couple of
days to finish all of the CG score it
and that like everything that they need
to broadcast it so the biggest reason
why they haven't shown you a lot of new
reverse flash is because they're just
not done with that post-production yet
but that should happen pretty quickly
and the thing is is I'm also working on
a new Justice League deleted scenes
video so that will be next but let me
know in the comments what's your theory
about the difference between Mobius
chair thinker and wheel chair thinker
like what is the connection because very
clearly it's the same person it's not
like he has a twin brother who's this
version of the thinker and he's this
other version it's got to be one person
so there has to be some way for him to
be both of these people but I have a
feeling that his wheelchair condition
has something to do with what he was
doing with the thinking cap in these
flashbacks the whole thing with the
Legion of super-heroes if you haven't
been watching Supergirl is that they
just found a ship in the harbor that's
been there for 12,000 years they have
all these mystery pods
they've only opened Saturn girls she's
just one of the core members of the
Legion of super-heroes so this is the ma
Nell roster brainiacs symbol is in the
background here so very clearly they're
gonna thaw him out pretty soon but all
of these symbols represent the different
members but I'll post that Justice
League deleted scenes video in the next
couple of hours before
the flash episode then I'll post my
flash episode video so we'll say
congratulations to the latest flash ring
giveaway winner Samuel Thomas 101 please
private message me on the back end of my
channel so I can get your contact
details there'll be a new round when I
post that Justice League video in a
little while you can click here for the
big crossover trailer and you can click
here for all my Justice League Easter
eggs thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight